welcome to another tutorial on C++ this
one is going to be on point tours so why
listen to my tutorial of pointers if
there's already a gazillion out there in
zillion tutorials and it's kind of like
that for all of these things I'm talking
about what C++ it's not like I'm the
first or certainly the last to make good
tutorial but I guess I don't know I'm
hoping you guys just like my voice I
guess at this point I'm gonna explain it
in the simplest way I know how from a
beginner perspective and hopefully that
helps someone out there because these
can be a little bit confusing but also
they're pretty simple so I'm just gonna
tell you it in my own way and hopefully
that is enough to make a difference and
make this video stand out a little bit
alright so first of all let's just open
up a file pointer
toriel and I'll just open this up of a
visual studio code I know I changed my
the background on my terminal it looks
like I'm a Mac one or something am I am
i rebel I might be a rebel I don't know
what's going on here alright well let's
just uh let's just make a file and what
we'll do this thing
get used to making this right here like
usual cuz you'll be doing it all the
time and save us a main dot cpp we're
also gonna do another new file and do a
make file like usual so you always want
to kind of do this with a new project in
general unless you have others some
other kind of make system or your IDE
handles it for you but this is just
something the initialization of a new
project is a main and a make file
usually when you're on Linux but that's
just the way I do it and it's a great
beginner strat when you don't want to
get too complicated but as you get more
advanced you find better ways making a
project so pointers
what are pointers pointers have a star
they're the same looking except they
have the star and then whatever you want
to name it integer data
so this is an integer that is a pointer
to an integer and it is just what like
what it sounds like it is not the actual
data itself is a pointer to a space and
memory that holds the data and C++ is
smart enough to realize that when you're
pointing to this location and data and
it's an integer that it's an integer so
for a lot of purposes it works
essentially the same but you do have to
dereference it to tell your program that
you want what's the pointers pointing at
or do you want the pointer itself so so
what's the point
Wow what's the point of pointers no pun
intended
well let's do a size of and we'll just
do a size of integer data and let's run
this so what's the site you remember the
size of an integer is 4 bytes right
integer is 4 bytes maybe this isn't the
best place to put that what are we on I
kind of lost track around 15 I might be
wrong pointers and the point ok good
enough and teacher data okay we'll call
this one pointer so there we go we have
an integer data just integer and this
should be 4 bytes however a pointer how
BIG's a pointer
let's find out by just doing a size of
operation on it so won't do a make hold
on we got to change directory to the one
we're actually in now we'll do make and
we'll run it and we get 8 so and what's
the size of just an integer
well let's find out says it was not
declared in this scope am i spelling it
wrong oh I did spell it wrong okay
that's that's no big deal we'll just
leave a typo so an integer is 4 bytes
while pointer is 8 bytes and so you know
maybe in this case it's not the best
idea because the pointer is larger but
usually well just to indicate a memory
read memory address and its type and all
the stuff that C++ needs to know it
needs 8 bytes and while that's more than
some of the smaller types it is a lot
less than the larger types so if you
have a giant array or a giant vector of
something or a huge class that you've
built on your own you can make a pointer
to it and it will always be 8 bytes to a
point to that memory and this is great
for passing around because you don't
want to necessarily pass around giant
pieces of data so there's that sort of
advantage and you can dereference it too
so let's take sleepies and let's just
work with our pointer here so if i put a
star in front of a pointer dereferences
it and tells it to just just look at the
data so in this case I should get a 4
because the data is 4 bytes so that's
how you dereference it if you have a
pointer and you just want the data you
don't wanna mess with the pointer
anymore you put a star and run it again
and it says now it's just the data type
now one of the interesting things about
pointers and sort of a pitfall in a lot
of programs even even big name programs
you'll you'll see in the patch notes of
pretty much every piece of software ever
fixed memory leaks fixed memory leaks
fixed memory leaks and the reason is
they don't delete their pointers now
what happens here when you when you
allocate a pointer when you initialize a
pointer it initializes the data and puts
the data there and
yeah yeah so well I said let me show you
something but within the scope of the
pointer I did a previous tutorial on
this that I don't know if it was good or
not but some people seem to like it when
you leave the scope see okay these
little brackets our scope of course so
it starts a like a new section of the
program declares this integer pointer
and of course an integer sets it to zero
and we're just doing a size of operation
then we're leaving scope now what
happens here when you leave scope is
this pointer is deleted but this data
that was being pointed to is still there
so it doesn't leave and you have to
manually tell it to leave by using the
Delete key it's your data pointer so
this actually cleans up the memory so if
you're doing a bunch of your calling
functions in your program and you're
using pointers in them you got to be
sure you're deleting the pointers after
you're completely done with them and
that can be a bit tricky and I said of a
pitfall so sometimes you'll notice the
program just continually uses more and
more memory longer runs to some infinite
amount and it's because they have some
function in there probably that is not
deleting their pointer to their data so
they're creating the data and leaves
scope deletes the access err to it but
it doesn't delete the data so those
that's sort of the basic advantage
disadvantages hey you get a you get a
small little tiny thing that points to
where the data is and it's cheap to pass
around it's cheap to to reference but
the pitfall is you got to remember to
delete it now there is a workaround to
this and then this was introduced in C++
11 and improved some 114 and that was in
the memory header and there's a thing
called unique pointer so unique pointer
means it deletes itself when it goes out
of scope no longer a need for the fleet
this delete key so it's on the standard
its unique PTR and then you put in these
little whatever alligator mouth things
less than greater than signed the type
you went to the pointer to B and here
we're calling it integer data pointer it
essentially works the same thing same
way and it doesn't really show here it's
uh it doesn't you can't really see here
that it D allocates because there's I
don't have anything and I don't I could
probably come up with some fancy code to
to show you but I can't think of
anything else top my head but just know
that when a unique pointer goes out of
scope it deletes the data so if if you
want to point her but you don't
necessarily want to mess with clean
enough and remember just use a unique
pointer you do have to be on C++
standard eleven wait I think how you do
this okay so and to make sure you're on
C++ standard 11 or 14 you go to your
compiled command you put a little -
standard equals C++ and then whatever
the version I'm going to say 14 in my
case and this will compile it with the
C++ 14 standard and unique pointers are
there so if you're on some of the old
standards I think there's 199 they don't
have this memory header doesn't have a
unique pointer so if you want to if you
want to specify the version of C++ you
can do that and there compiles and I can
run it and it looks like it said eight
because I'm just looking at the pointer
so as you can see here a unique pointer
is still just eight bytes and not too
big of a size there is also shared
pointer double click there we go
and a share pointer is very similar to a
unique pointer except that it only
deletes the data when the last reference
to it is gone
so if you if you want multiple parts of
your program to have access to this data
but you don't necessarily want to manage
it all individually you can just make
make a shared pointer have them all
reference it and when the last one is
done it goes out of scope then it
deletes so if you need multiple access
to it you want to share it pointer if
you want single access to it you want a
unique pointer and if you just want the
old school raw pointer you just do the
star thing we were doing in the
beginning so I'm gonna go ahead and
compile it one last time here and as you
can see a shared pointer is two bytes so
it is a little bit larger but it it's
not that much larger but sometimes
that's what you need and it can save you
a lot of headache too so you share
pointers once your program gets pretty
large and you have lots of pieces of it
accessing the same thing it can be very
very nice and I think that will do it
for this tutorial about pointers really
just the very basics there if you want
to learn more I highly recommend looking
up shared pointers unique pointers and I
don't know if there's some demand I will
happily do some more advanced stuff on
them myself to let me know if you have
any questions don't forget to leave a
like on this video if it helped you out
or if you just want to support the
channel I have recently made a patreon
I'll leave a link to that below to try
to continue with this channel and get
some funding to make some better videos
so really appreciate anyone that wants
to sign up there I'm still working on
getting some tier levels and all that
fancy stuff that people do but every
view every like helps and you know a
small channel looking to grow alright
peace out guys hope you have a great day
and I'll catch you in the next video